coût éventuel de la mesure 13 millions
d'euros pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines jusque là le
territoire bénéficie d'une pondération
fiscale du fait de son ancien statut de
ville nouvelle
un avantage aujourd'hui remise en cause
par un amendement déposé pendant les
fêtes de fin d'année et qui menace les
finances de l'agglomération
quand vous avez plus de dix billets ou à
trouver d'assez soit vous réduisez les
services à la population
soit vous réduisez votre investissement
soit vous augmentez les impôts donc
chaque fois ce seront les habitants qui
seront pénalisés face à cette décision
également impacté par la fin de cet
avantage fiscal les communes pour un
coût de 120 à 150 mille euros pour la
verrière 250000 euros pour coignières et
plus d'un million d'euros pour la ville
de maurepas je ne sais plus comment
faire nous sommes pris à la gorge
en plus de toutes les autres réformes
qui sont sur les collectivités la prime
points pour les fonctionnaires le
déverrouillage du point d'indicé vous
avez également la baisse de la dotation
générale de fonctionnement
j'ai perdu 2,5 millions d'euros depuis
2014 je fais comment j'ai fait plus de
deux millions d'euros d'économies depuis
que je suis élu je n'ai pas été élu pour
détruire soutenu dans un communiqué par
la gauche la majorité saint-quentinoise
est désormais lancé dans une course
contre la montre à partir du 28 février
prochain le travail parlementaire sera
gelé en vue des échéances électorales